president biden is restricting travel
from india
over that country's coronal virus surge
before he was
elected you may remember then-candidate
biden criticized president trump
for what he called hysterical xenophobia
on the same day
that then president trump announced a
travel ban to china
because of the virus state department
correspondent rich edson
has a situation report tonight
citing extraordinarily high covet 19
case loads and multiple variants
circulating there
the biden administration announced the
united states will restrict travel from
india starting next week we as a country
have made a commitment to the people of
india to support
them a year ago the trump campaign
accused then-candidate biden of calling
the china travel ban
xenophobic biden also tweeted that quote
banning all travel from europe or any
other part of the world
will not stop it referring to the
viruses spread biden's campaign said his
reference to trump's xenophobia
was related to the former president
scapegoating others
not his china travel ban biden's
campaign also said he backed travel
restrictions
that experts support it in the opening
days of his administration
biden tightened international travel
restrictions reversing a late order from
president trump who had relaxed them
india is now on that list where crowded
hospitals are turning away patients
even if they manage a spot oxygen
supplies are often spent
my father's dead body was lying there
when i asked what happened there was no
one to inform us
and later when i spoke to a nurse there
she told me that they ran out of oxygen
supply in the morning
nearly four hundred thousand new daily
coveted cases breaking global records
there are medicine and testing shortages
a thriving black market for supplies and
overwhelmed crematoria
this week the state department renewed
its level four warning for india urging
americans
not to travel there department officials
are also offering family members of
american diplomats in india
the option to leave the country the u.s
government says it's sending
100 million dollars worth of covet aid
just as india
sent assistance to the united states
when our hospitals were strained early
in the pandemic
the united states is determined to help
india in its time of need
the first shipments of oxygen cylinders
diagnostic kits and masks
are arriving in india the biden
administration has also pledged to
release
60 million doses of astro zenica
astrazeneca vaccines to other countries
as they become available
that vaccine is not approved for use in
the united states
brett richardson at the state department
rich thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else